Hey, Ira.
Hello.
Will Andy be joining? I mean, Andy Arora or Leon?
No.
Okay, it's just the two of us.
Yes.
Okay.
See.
Yeah, Ashley.
Hi, how are we doing, Ayra?
Good afternoon, I'm good.
Good afternoon. Good, good. Doing pretty good. Just walking back to my desk, sorry.
How about you?
It's fine.
For your lunch?
No, no, no. It's only 1130. It's only 1130. We don't take lunch till close till like 2.
Oh, okay, 11.
Okay, too late lunch, huh?
Yeah, yeah, late lunch.
I make sure everybody else goes. Leaders eat less.
Yeah.
I understand that. Have you met Justin?
Um, I don't think I have, not that I recall.
Hey.
Not yet, yeah. Hi, Ashley.
Thank you.
Hi.
So I'm going to be your customer success manager. I'm just going to be on the call right now just to see how things are going, but hopefully sooner I'll be able to connect with you as well. And if ever you have anything that you need outside, you know, assistance of your engineers, you can just reach out to me.
Ohh.
Perfect.
I won't be turning on my camera, sorry, by the way, I'm at home right now. And we have some issues here in the Philippines, but yeah, hopefully soon.
Alright.
Okay.
Is it the fuel?
Nice to meet you, Justin.
Is it the fuel thing, Justin? That first strike. Yeah, it's been going on a lot. Are you feeling it too, Ashley, in your country? The fuel?
Nice to meet you too.
Yeah, the transport strike.
Yes, oh, our gas prices are insane right now. Yes, yes. Absolutely.
Insane.
One 100% increase.
Ohh yeah, yeah, price.
But luckily we have a rollback this coming Tuesday.
Ohh, you do? Nice. We have no, we have no, no relief on the horizon quite yet, so...
Yeah. How about yours, but Rahman?
Hopefully, it will get better soon, yeah.
We will, yeah, we'll see.
OK, let me.
Doesn't usually get better until like.
political season when everyone wants to make false promises. Then it gets better for a little while.
I know.
Let's just leave it to them.
Right, alright.
I know. Anyways, let me just share my deck here. Let me know once you see it.
Okay, I can see it.
Okay, perfect. All right.
Thank you, Justin and Ashley, for joining our bi-weekly service call. Our review will cover April 8th to 19th. Moving on to the agenda items, all of which are the same.
For here, the action tracker, I did.
Ask RJ to submit his pending time sheet. I hope that's completed already on your end. Did you see it?
Sorry, I didn't realize I was muted. Sorry about that.
Sorry, it's okay.
No.
Any pending?
I apologize. I am trying to get better. So I do have, let me just, he did submit a bunch of them to me. I think the only ones I am missing is last week's. I didn't get last week's yet. Timesheet.
Last week's time should be okay. Let me remind him with that.
Yeah, last week's time sheet, that's on my agenda to address with you because he did not, did not fill out his time sheet all the way.
Okay, let me just check that with him. And the second item, scheduled the board review with RJ. So that's done. I did a book it on his calendar. So that's 30 minutes every Thursday and Friday. So we're also doing the board review. I'm just trying to get to know
I.
Mhm.
his daily task as well as the auto task that tickets that he's working on. So once I see anything, once I have concerns or if I need help with that, I'll surely ping you. But then I'm not sure if, are you like,
PH.
Khan.
Is it okay if I ping you or do you have like a specific time where you want me to have a discussion? Anytime?
No, you can.
You can just, yeah, you can just send me a message if you have questions.
All right, thanks for that.
8 to 5 PST time frame, just so you know.
Okay, alrighty.
Ohh.
Yes, for the check-in, how are things going at the moment with you and RJ?
They're okay. It's hard. I don't see RJ for a couple days and then it's been a really busy week. So probably today has been our most interactions today because I needed him to kind of switch gears. I think he just gets easily distracted.
if I'm being honest. Like he was, I asked him to be flexible with some tickets this morning and he did a great job. He answered, he was flexible, he moved on, like everything was great. And then he like finished early and his next appointment was until 12. And so he went to start a tentative, which was awesome. That's the process, right?
But then he stopped working the tentative without actually doing anything. Like he started it and then unstarted it. And I'm like, hey, were you going to work on that one? Or like, because his firm for 12 o'clock actually had called in. So the plan was to ask him to start that early.
But then I saw him go green, his appointment go green. So I followed up with him like, hey, you agreed and then you disappeared. Like, are you going to work on that? He's like, actually, I'm talking with John about a login issue on another ticket. Like, that has nothing to do with what you're working on. Like, why are you left right now? Like, why are we up here?
It's not any of the tickets you were just working on and it's not any of the tickets that you have right now. I'm not really sure what we're doing. So it's just a little distracting. And so I asked him, I said, okay, I'm just checking in because you know your user had called and so I was going to ask you to start a little bit early. He's like, I could do it.
Like, okay, so like, was our 20 minute pause to like talk to John really like a thing or not a thing? He just seems to be distracted A lot. Like where there's just random pauses. And I'm not necessarily saying he's not doing anything because it sounds like he's working with the team. I'm just not sure how helpful it is.
And I'm not sure how efficient it is. Or if he should be reaching out like when he's got the ticket or if he wasn't able to solve the login ticket, like why is he coming back to it two hours later? Neither of the tickets he was on are logins. So I'm not, I'm really not sure. But.
He's been working on some critical, so I haven't really had a chance to put a pause to have the conversation with him about, hey, like, what's going on? How's it going? So full transparency, all of this just happened within the last hour and a half, so I haven't really had a chance to recap it.
Okay, thanks for letting me know about that, Ashley, for the detailed explanation of what happened. I was actually speaking to him like 15 minutes ago. I was checking on his tickets and I did saw that he was talking to someone about a login issue.
And is that not part of his calendar today?
I don't, I just don't know what ticket it's for because the ones that he had been scheduled weren't weren't login tickets.
Okay, alright.
So I'm just not, I'm not sure. Maybe it was related to an issue and like there was another complaint like while he was on the phone.
Yeah.
about a login as well. And so he thought he would check on it. All of that could be totally viable and make sense. So like, I'm not trying to say he's doing anything wrong. I'm just saying, I don't know. It feels like this and I haven't had a chance to talk to him and been like, are you going off? Are you like, is it making sense? I'm not sure where you are.
Mm.
Mhm.
It's fine. But I did hear him talking to someone. He said that a user is with me and he's asking for these details. That's what I saw from his chat. But then I'll check and double check with him for you. And you mentioned you will also have...
PH.
Got it.
We will also talk to him today, right? About that. Okay. So that will also help. So we can clear the...
Yeah.
the miscommunication on this part. But then I can also see sometimes that he's a bit distracted when someone pings him for another ticket. So he will drop the thing that he's working on and respond to the chat. So there's an opportunity there to work on and I'll make sure.
To handle that for you.
Yeah, it just depends, right? Like I want him to be responsive to his dispatchers who are asking him to be flexible, like to be responsive. That's not necessarily a bad thing. It's, you know, I called him, he was really nice and put on, he had a user on the phone and he said,
I'm answering you, but I have someone on hold. And I was like, no problem. I will be super fast. And it was really just I needed him to wrap up that call quickly so that he could switch gears. What he was working on was really backend work, and I needed something for a user that was completely down. So I'm not.
saying he's never going to get pooled or never going to have to be asked to reprioritize what he has on his calendar. It's just more of like, when we finish something early, what are you doing with your time? Like, how are you moving efficiently through your time sheets?
Okay, gotcha. And I believe that will fix the issue if he would put time entries on the things that he's doing daily, right? Even if it's just checking the server. So it's very important to take note of that on the ticket so that when we have a review, we will see it that, oh, okay, he's busy this day.
Yeah.
is busy that time. Okay, I'll take note of that.
Right.
All right, anything else before we proceed?
No, go ahead.
Okay, perfect. ITBD recommended KPIs, we already know that. So let's continue with the billable utilization trend. This is for two weeks, April 8th to 19th. Our target in IT by Design, that's 80%.
That's the recommended KPI. But then we can see a downward trend here. For Thursdays and Wednesdays, or maybe I can say Wednesday to Friday, I can't see any issues with the utilization at all. But then this is where we're having issues for
Uh-huh.
the weekend part. I did check in with him. Did you get any tickets for that week? He said that not pretty much tickets. And last week we also tried to move any tentative ticket, but then we can't really do it because it needs to be closed.
Yeah.
that day. So I'm still trying to figure out, I'm still trying to find ways to add tickets to his weekends. But then he said that Sue sent him a document about a night shift SOP.
Uh-huh.
So he's most of his time for the past week and he's reading that. But then Jesus said he still needs to discuss it with him. Not sure when will it happen. He doesn't have any schedule yet. But then are you aware of that night shift SOP?
Yeah, there is a, well, it's a after hours SOP. So for him, it's the Saturday and Sunday work, what he should be doing and how he should be proceeding through it. It's, it is a slightly long document, but it's not that long to read. It's like 16 pages, but it's a lot of screenshots.
in the 16 pages, like I managed to read it in an hour. It's not terribly long. And he'll probably just need to have it for reference, like.
somewhere saved down at the bottom icon like as he practices the SOP requirements.
But...
I will get with Jesus to make sure that he has reviewed it with him for any kind of clarity that he needs on it. But yeah, I would say it is, it shouldn't be terribly hard to discuss. Yeah, right.
Mhm.
To understand, right? Yeah. And also, I'm thinking if we can add that to his weekend time sheet, the training, the time entry, what do you think?
S.
I am.
Yeah, I mean, his training should still be logged in a ticket. He can create a network builders ticket for his training time of going over it with Jesus or reviewing the document. But it's really, I mean, it shouldn't be an ongoing ticket and it shouldn't be something that takes him that long.
Yu.
It's like a one-time training.
Non-billable site.
And then...
Yeah, it's not billable. No, it's not billable, but it will help his total utilization, because his total utilization is still not where it needs to be. So, yeah.
Okay.
Yes.
Okay, so we'll do that this coming weekend. Do you think 2 hours a day would work? Saturday and Sunday, 2 hours?
I don't think he's going to need 2 hours a day. Ira, honestly, like if he puts 2 hours on Saturday, he should pretty much have that like finished and reviewed. And then if he has questions on Sunday, he can schedule himself to like reach out to Jesus for like 30 minutes to go over any questions he has, maybe an hour, but.
Okay.
Done it, OK.
Other than that, that's...
That's enough.
We didn't change so much that like his whole workflow is different. What we changed is like how we expect him to like communicate certain things. What we changed is, you know, how to document certain pieces. But it shouldn't be like a whole workflow that he just doesn't understand.
Yeah.
Okay, gotcha. So that two hours, I will let him add it to his time, to his calendar, so it would help us increase his utilization over the weekend. And also I'm thinking, are there any other tasks that we can give him? Like,
Um...
up checking server maintenance on weekends.
I mean, I think that's coming. We're rebuilding our NOC. So I think that's coming as part of it, but I don't have that for him right now. I do have some weekend work this weekend. I have probably about four computers that need to be set up, three for some new users. So like there's no one to contact. It's just start setting them up. They're brand new. You already have the passwords like.
just get the computer set up. They're in my office, so like they're already on.
When he called earlier this morning for Jennifer, he said he got her login details. I asked him to just go ahead and get a list of what she needed and then we could work on it later as long as it was on. Make sure he could connect to it. So there should be no issues in him working on that this weekend as long as he set himself up for success and make sure to tell Jennifer, leave.
the computer on, the laptop on, then he should be really good there. But I think there's three, three computers, 4 computers that need to be set up. Two are just being set up as spares. Like there's absolutely no reason why those can't get to the point of spares and a Bluebeam install on them. Like it's really, really quick.
Okay, that will help for this week, so that's good. We have two pending time entries ready for the training and the computer setup. Will that be assigned to him?
Yes, yeah, I can actually move them now and put them on his Saturday, Sunday schedule, because there's one that's scheduled for next, but there's plenty of other things he could work on that he could work on this on Saturday.
All right. Yay. That's cool. So that's that. And then if any other projects that you can assign to him every weekend, that would help us as well, Ashley. So in case you have time or you have any tickets pending or any projects that he can work on,
Please do let us know, or you can assign it to him so he can work on it.
Okay.
Okay, thank you.
For the ticket closure trend and analysis, so I can see an upward trend here for two weeks. For the peak week was from April 15th to 19th. The resolution rate was 80%. That's good. But then before that, we only have 70%.
I.
But then it's a good number for me. I can see that there's a progress there.
Any questions for this?
Are we good? Okay.
Yeah.
For the way forward, we have an upcoming ITBD holiday, that's May 1st. I would just like to check if you need him that day or you want him to take me off.
No, everybody will be working that day.
Okay, so he can take the day off.
No, no. I need him to come in. Yes.
Oh, he needs to. All right. Got that. I'll take note of that. And also he's requesting for a birthday PTO this coming May 6th and 7th. I did send you an email. Were you able to review it?
Oh, I did not, but let me just take a look.
Okay.
May 6th and 7th is what you said.
Yes, correct. Six and seven, that's...
Okay, I will respond to it in just a minute. That way you have it in writing.
Hey.
OK, thank you. Just look into it. If you need him, I can let him know, but then if...
No problem.
The Wednesday, Thursday. That's a really hard one. Okay. Yes, I'll have to talk with Jesus because that's a really hard one. Those are the days where he's alone. Oh, he's alone. So that's hard. I will double check.
Yeah.
Yes, please.
Okay.
All right, that's cool. So I can probably circle back next week so we can give him the answer. And then that's it. That's the end of my slide. I'm going to stop sharing my screen so we can see each other. Yeah, there. Anything you wanted to discuss?
Play.
Yep.
Fact?
With us.
So just the pieces we talked about, it looks like he did really well the week before on his timesheet. Let me know when you can see my screen.
Yes, I can see it.
Okay, so it looks like, like the week before where he submitted his timesheet, he did end up rounding out his time, which is really good. But like last week, it does seem like we didn't finish. So therefore, probably a reason why he didn't submit it.
But see, like, we're not at our 9th. Like, we're way off.
And even still like these ones I'm having a hard time with like I'm not sure.
why we're ending up so low. If you look, I think this was the day he was sick. He worked half day. Do you remember? He didn't come until five. So his time sheet, yeah, so his time sheet should have some time logged as like his
Yes, Kasper.
PTO time or however he chose to use that time, absence should have that logged as well there. And then in these ones where he's only really accounting for six hours, like if you see looking through it, like there's like time gaps, right, where we're missing a little bit here.
Like he took off early, but then probably took a lunch right around here around 4:00.
which would make sense for like the long period. But then you get into the after hours portion. And so we're just looking for like the little small things. I'm looking at the small things that try to tell me if he's being like efficient with his time or not. Sorry, but there's like right here.
If you think it's almost 1/2 an hour of like missing time.
Mhm, mhm.
Like he stopped working at 1215 and like didn't come back till 1240. But that's not a lunch. But his lunch is an hour. He took it at two, right? Like two to three. That would make sense. But like, I'm not sure what you're doing with 40 minutes, 30 minutes of time, like where it's just unaccounted for. And that definitely like eats.
Mhm.
I.
Okay.
So, but as it adds to a total.
Does that make sense? So like here we've got another like 25 minutes where we don't, I don't, I'm not sure.
Mm.
Ohh.
I'm not sure what's happening.
And then at the end of the day, he's got like, this is technically a Thursday, a Thursday, so he's off at 9 and like our time entry stops at 630.
Mhm.
He stops at 6:30, right?
Right, but his shift goes until 9, I think.
Okay.
Talk to.
No, this is Friday. This is Friday. So his shift only goes till 7. Okay, so we're only missing 1/2 an hour, the last half an hour. This is Friday. Sorry, my days are...
Okay. Okay.
It's okay.
The time sheet doesn't go in the same order as the rest of the time, so it's throwing me off.
And.
Yeah.
Just a quick question: Are we not putting a time entry for lunch and breaks, or can we do?
Yes.
Yes, no, he is supposed to be putting a time entry for lunch and breaks. So if you look at the previous week, he does know how to log his lunch and breaks.
Yeah, okay, that's...
He should be logging every day, but again, he just...
Didn't do last week, so like it's not a habit yet.
Yeah.
So.
which was great, but then he played catch-up probably last week, and then this week just hasn't gone back. So, because if you look at this week, this is the week we're in.
no round outs. Like he should be rounding out at the end of every shift.
Okay.
Yeah, that's what I'm about to say. I'm thinking that it's doing it weekly. Okay.
Not at the end of every week.
Right, and it needs to be daily at the end of every day. His last thing that he does in the last like 3 minutes of his time should be timesheet. I log my lunch, I log my break, I log my payroll wrap.
Okay.
Yeah, like everything right? So, don't have any discrepancies with the time. OK, I'll check in.
Right.
And then that way on his last day of the week for the timesheet, which is Saturday, all he has to do is log his break, log his lunch, log his payroll wrap, and hit submit, and he's done. Like if everything is done daily, like it's supposed to, then it's only one extra step when he leaves Saturday to just hit the submit button rather than go back and have to update and spend time.
Mm.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, I got that. Yeah. When I was a tech, I do that daily. That's the best practice, right?
Yeah.
Well, I mean, that's our policy. Like, it's listed as a non-negotiable at the end of his shift every day that he leaves with his timesheet completed. He's just not been doing it.
Mm.
Okay, I'll remind him. I'll remind him. Okay, I'll handle that for you. I'll let him know. I'll have it documented as well. Apart from that, anything else you wanted to discuss?
Okay.
I think that's it for right now. That's all I had is really just trying to get that stuff done so we can be in a better spot.
Okay, I will make sure to help you on that one, because we're partners. Okay, anything you want to say, Justin?
You good?
I know you're observing us.
Yeah, I'm good. I just saw the thousands of tabs Ashley had in her desktop. So how do you even manage that?
And that's only one of my browsers open. You didn't even see my other screen.
Ha ha ha!
Yeah, yeah, but yeah, I, it's good to meet you, Ashley, and we'll be talking more soon.
Huh.
Yes.
Nice to meet you, Justin. Don't be scared of my browser tabs. That's how my brain works.
All right.
It's actually very intimidating. When I have around 10 to 12 tabs, I really wanted to quit already and I saw yours, but oh my god, that's around 30 tabs.
If it's open, that means I...
Yes.
Oh.
Yeah.
Yeah, you'll get used to it. I have mine like 30 years different.
Yeah, you'll get used to it.
Ohh my God.
It'll be fine.
Because it's hard to open it every time you need it, right? So it's nice to have it open every time.
Yep.
And you just get used to just having too many things and you don't close it until you know you're done with it. So like I have stuff that I know I need to just go back to. So I keep it open. And then as the day goes on, like the tabs get smaller, Justin. And then like, oh, I'm down to my last five tabs. All right, perfect. Everything got finished.
PH.
Yeah.
Best explanation. You got it right.
Yeah, yeah, so it's like a checklist; you just keep going.
Okay, cool.
Okay. Well, have a great weekend. Let's see what this weekend looks like. Check in with him for me, Ayra. I will put the computer setups on his schedule. And if there's any issues, let me know.
Mhm.
I can try to step in and help out, but these computers are going to be back end work. He shouldn't need to. As long as he called Jennifer and talked to Jennifer, that one should be good. And the rest are for brand new users and spares. So there should be no roadblocks.
Okay, so I'll let him know. I'll... He should call Jennifer today, right?
He already called Jennifer earlier when he first started. That was his first ticket. So as long as he got what he needed out of his phone call with Jennifer, then there should be no reason why he can't work on it this weekend.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
short of it's off and he didn't tell her to leave it on. Let's hope he told her to leave it on.
Okay, I'll let him know. Okay. So thank you so much for this productive meeting. Nice meeting you today, Ashley. Have a happy weekend for you, both of you. Bye.
Okay. Perfect. Thank you.
You too. Thanks. Bye.
Happy weekend, Ashley. Bye bye.